[Music]
hey everybody it's our special Christmas
edition of the 13 o'clock podcast not
Christmas yeah I know well cuz you know
this will be out on Tuesday and
Christmas is Sunday so we thought we'd
do kind of a little Christmas kind of
theme would you dig up for us this time
well we're gonna do well you know
everybody's heard of like the Krampus
right the promise if you want to say it
like that but what maybe a lot of people
know like you know that's gotten very
popular in the last few years but
actually from a lot of places around the
world particularly Eastern Europe and in
Iceland and stuff like that there's
actually a lot of other really weird
monsters and like other kind of
creatures or like bad dudes that
whooping a Santa Claus okay so what's
Knightly Brown so we're calling this one
we're calling this one creepy Christmas
creatures okay cuz I like the literation
that sounds good well I don't know
anything about this so I'm just gonna be
the audience today and now let's ask
questions and you can take me for a ride
with all this stuff that you look dug up
yeah did she do
I dig ya you dig stuff up then show it
to people stuff now and I have to say I
mean I had been one I wasn't sure if I
want to do a theme to him but I said you
know I feel like the modern-day they've
kind of lost the old like creepiness
that Christmas used to have because I
mean like in the Victorian era it was
traditional to read ghost stories on
Christmas they're a lot you know yeah
like Charles Dickens and all that and
you know so that was a traditional thing
to do and I feel like that's not really
like that traditions kind of been lost
used to be kinda like a Grimm's fairy
tale yeah and I really really like that
aspect of the holiday and it's a shame
that it's not more recognized but in a
lot of other cultures it still is
because you know now like particularly
in the west where we have Christmas and
it's all happy [ __ ] you know Santa
and angels and elves and they were
bringing presents to all the children
and blah-de-blah but you know in a lot
of other cultures Santa has like dark
counterparts
yeah I think that I think Christmas was
mostly invented by the coca-cola Cup but
he wouldn't know that's it that's
actually an urban legend applause Santa
Claus came from you know actual people
like you know Saint Nicholas and all
that kind of stuff and what he was
wearing but that that is a pretty common
urban legend a lot of people there but
it's not he's actually much he's
actually a much older character he came
over with the Dutch immigrants just
talking about Star Wars yes we saw we
got up early this morning it's might
we're recording this on Monday yeah we
got up early this morning and went to
see wrote one it was good it was pretty
epic I got it today I I'm gonna go ahead
and say that people are gonna say that
wrote one is better than force awakens
it's a different kind of very different
but I think people are gonna like I
think people are gonna say that one's
better it's yeah I mean force awakens
was kind of like was a fun movie this
one was kind of a dark it's like a war
film yeah there's essentially a war
movie those cool just kind of uh you
know gives you some hope that they'll be
able to do you know a bunch of cool side
stories around now I think the next and
I think I just read today that aren't
the the next one that's coming out in
2018 the of the next quote-unquote
anthology film yeah I think it's a Han
Solo Oh cack story okay I put like a
young Han Solo so yeah that actually
might be cool although we were talking
to the car on the way back that we
thought I want to draw Vader one yeah we
thought it would be cold not not like
you know Anakin Skywalker so you know
that was lame but but kind of a thing
where Darth Vader goes on a quest to
like find like a system remember in that
minute and the last time we talked about
Star Wars last week yeah watch that
episode where we won't talk about Star
Wars the whole time I know yeah I was
saying that I believe
Snoke is Darth Plagueis the wise
wouldn't surprise me you could make a
side mission Vader goes out to find
Darth Plagueis the wise and help
resurrect him somehow yes see that would
be Super Bowl and then that would like
all tie in with force awakens it would
tie all of it together
yeah Peter kodik going to some ancient
Sith temple to find you know Darth
Plagueis and somehow brings him back to
life or helps resurrect him something
like that you know he has to go through
these sip tombs and crabs see this is
why I said on last week's show that you
should write these movies yeah I could
write it right a cool one like that you
could yeah anyway anyway just get back
to what we're doing Christmas
so like I said probably everybody by now
you know they made that that movie
Krampus that was about Krampus and that
was actually it was a pretty
entertaining it's a horror comedy it was
fun I particularly like the murderous
gingerbread men that was pretty read but
so most people are familiar with that
but there are a lot of other characters
now Krampus they didn't really go into
this in the movie so much which i think
is maybe what a lot of people will be
familiar with but it's kind of like
Krampus is actually he comes with Santa
Claus he does yeah the sleigh is not so
intimidating when you think oh yeah you
know San is the guy that brings stuff to
all the good children mm-hmm
while Krampus is the one that if you're
if the kid's been bad you know Krampus
will take the kids and stuff him in a
bag and either eat them or take them to
hell that's awesome yeah and he's the
day he has like he has some like you
know cloven hooves and everything yeah
that's back we used to tell you kids the
truth right so sanitized
I mean think out rad that used to be
like you could say you better not be
better Krampus is gonna yeah yeah and he
looks like a devil and everything's your
fault you know get with the program kid
but yeah so but like I said in other
parts of the world Santa has other
companions who are usually like you know
meeting out the punishment right so say
they can get all the accolades for being
the good guy right but it's a good cop
bad cop oh my god
sis you know Santa's gonna come break
presents and his little buddies are
gonna like beat the kids in the
submission between presents are getting
eaten oh yeah I'm in her hell yeah I
think I'll take those presents oh yeah
oh yeah I definitely wanted the present
yeah
but yeah so other than Krampus um
another German guy wouldn't Krampus
actually look like though before we get
oh and different he looks kind of like
he looks kind like the devil honestly he
usually has like big horns he has like a
tongue sticking out okay cloven who was
that kind of stuff okay it's funny
because a lot of like old German
Christmas cards like you can look up
some of them we'll have pictures of the
cram like this terrifying looking black
thing with with horns and [ __ ] like
stuff and new kids in a bag and the kids
facial expressions are so austere like
in the in the movie that they made I
think it came out in 2014 or 2015 the
you know the horror comedy they made
Krampus was actually not eating the
children but he was taking them to hell
alright so he put him in a bag and he
throw and actually you meet him later
yeah actually he wasn't just killing the
children he was killing everybody right
like just boiler alert if you're kids
you might as well just kill everybody oh
yeah they just killed everybody and he
killed everybody because they forgot
about the Christmas spirit because they
were getting all crabby and [ __ ] okay
that's good yeah so that was that was
the direction they took it but
traditionally the character is there to
beat the kids if they're bad yeah or to
end take them away now there's another
one in Germany and plea and I know I'm
gonna murder all the parents coming up
with weird [ __ ] the Germans I love or or
the people in Iceland have
[ __ ] up once - actually the ones that
Iceland are more [ __ ] up than that
yeah Germans you can see why Bjork is so
weird yeah when you get that white you
come up with some weird [ __ ]
so I mean forgive me because I know I'm
gonna murder all these pronunciations
cuz you know I don't speak German and I
don't speak Icelandic
just do it but there's another one
called next Ruprecht and now he is kind
of like Santa Claus but the kids Brecht
huh rubric okay it's almost Klingon yeah
Santa's attendant Klingon yeah and he
yes he is st. Nicholas's attendant and
he carries the bag of gifts so Santa
doesn't even have to carry the [ __ ]
presents man cuz Santa's the man and
he's the boss
and he has people for that all right so
next Ruprecht mm-hmm he carries the bag
of gifts however he also has a big rod
you know what the [ __ ] presents okay
this is kind of going off in directions
I didn't even expect and it's wonderful
mommy good mood yeah that's good yeah we
just have pizza and we just out Star
Wars that's yeah that's pretty rad now
we need is eggnog and rum
well we can have some of that later and
we'll play some Christmas music yea-ah
that'll be a fun idea alright alright
yeah so and here's a funny thing a lot
of these like German you know
Netherlands stuff like that like Oh a
lot of these Santa's attendants have are
black like they and when people dress up
as them they wear black for
right which as you can tell is a little
problematic in the modern era
how would it though yeah they still do
it yeah um it's kind of controversial
nowadays but next Ruprecht is actually
black because of suit because he's
supposed to be crawling over the
chimneys and stuff like that and so you
know so if people that dress up as him
and people still do it in Germany
nowadays I don't you know the tradition
might be fading now because America you
know America's Christmas traditions are
kind of taken everything but so but
sometimes you see the guys have like
beards and they have like a big broad a
big staff you know to beat kids with
like you do and you know they have bags
of ashes so I'm not entirely sure what
that's for but so what
what next rubric does is he grills the
kids on whether they've been praying or
not okay and then if the kids have been
praying and he gives them like a text
like a pop quiz right about their
prayers and stuff and then if the kids
pass the test then they get all kinds
they get fruit and candy and gingerbread
and all that good stuff you know if they
get the questions wrong then he'll beat
the [ __ ] stuff only back in the
hockey motherland and funnily enough
next Ruprecht he also gives like crappy
gifts to bad kids to like rocks or coal
or whatever and so you know that might
have been work cuz it seems like the
American Santa he kind of gets he
doesn't beat kids to death or anything
or eat them or anything it's not that I
know of and except in those couple of
horror movies but you know they've you
know he'll that's the worst he'll do
right it's okay that's a give you a
piece of coal yeah if you [ __ ] up yeah
which you know I'm not bringing yet or
not working switches [ __ ] you
maybe some switches and you get no Xbox
this year yeah have your coal and like
it yeah what's next
um so okay so another one is called
Belsnickel Belsnickel Belsnickel that
sounds like a flavor of ice cream in it
you need two scoops of that well what
would the flavor be be kind of like
eggnog and snickerdoodle oh my god it's
called Ben and Jerry's new holiday
Belsnickel flavor yeah Belsnickel that
actually does that pretty awesome now
Belsnickel he's kind of considered he's
considered a companion of Santa but he
comes separately he doesn't come with
Santa he's got his own ride he's not
Santa's [ __ ] he comes in on uber uber
two breaks the door so here's what I'm
thinking though so like Santa comes with
next rupprecht and Krampus and all that
they're beating the children there but
Belsnickel comes at a different time and
I'm like how many [ __ ] presents are
these kids getting goddamn I never got
that much [ __ ] hand them out had them
out you know yeah it's done it's time to
get prison get presents or get beaten
the weird occasions might be both at the
same time yeah some kids might like that
right that is their present that was the
genesis thank you sir may I have another
to the BDSM seat but yeah so all the
Belsnickel will do he doesn't beat the
kids to death he just threatens them
like like you know how like in The
Godfather with the horse head in the bed
yeah it's that kind of thing he won't
leave a big stick in your stockings okay
yeah he won't actually a hitch boot
that's like the threat yeah yeah give
you warnings so Belsnickel is not and
he's not really um a monster per se like
he wears a mask and he's kind of creepy
looking but he looks like a person like
whenever he looks like a little short
back okay now remember when I said
earlier I felt the blackface yeah okay
well there's another
when he's caught and I don't want to
pronounce the Dutch one but I'm gonna
try called
wart picked which i think is the Dutch
it's also called black Peter okay and
the this is a sort of Dutch I believe
but I think they know of him in England
too because I think in England they call
it black Peter although it started out
in the Netherlands and yeah he's a
helper of st. Nicholas now he has to go
over the roofs and kind of essentially
he's Santa's reconnaissance team like he
has to go around on the roofs and look
in the chimneys and make sure the kids
aren't misbehaving she's got a lot of
work to do before the sleigh shows up
yeah check it all out that's what I mean
he's like yeah he's he's got to go in
there first and check everything out
right now black Peter started out as and
like I said the character whenever you
see somebody in the character and if you
go in the Wikipedia page for his work
Pete or black Peter you'll see what it
looks like it's usually someone in
blackface with like a renaissance
looking dad's on like a like one of the
puffy Rembrandt hats and like this big
ass [ __ ] yeah and they also have
lipstick and earrings on although I
don't know why that is
looks like he's in drag yeah and there's
like and and also they have kind of a
big fluffy after a wig like I don't
understand here's the thing he started
out he was supposed to be a more from
Spain right which is why he's in why
it's blackness so I don't know but I
don't know why like okay a curly afro
wig all right I don't like it but I
understand what but with lipstick and
earrings though why it's supposed to be
a dude
it's not black Patricia it's black Peter
I don't know Peter I don't get it so I
don't and I don't think anybody else
knows either they're just like that's
you know I can't lipstick and earrings
well the earrings you have something to
do it's like being a Seafarer it could
be that yeah but we'll explain the
lipstick
that's just how that's just how they're
doing it yeah they're just that's just
how they roll okay so yeah so but you
know these care these characters I mean
they're so rooted far back in history
because I'm sure as everyone listening
knows is a smart they probably don't
know where that game and they probably
don't but like I said I mean all of the
traditions like Christmas traditions are
so old yeah and I mean you know how some
people like Oh put Christ back in
Christmas you [ __ ] that they're if
they're it's pagan it goes like
thousands and thousands of thousands of
years and everything we have now
partying the [ __ ] Christmas trees the
Holly the mistletoe all that stuff is
[ __ ] pagan and it is thousands and
thousands of years old I don't even know
where camera and they probably don't
even know they're just like would use we
just do this my parents didn't like this
my grandpa's a big wooden geology make a
good analogy if if you go to a trump
rally you're gonna see somebody dressed
up as a wall but bricks on them and
really yeah would that be a trip of 100
years from now you're just gonna have a
character called the wall who walks
around the dude dressed up as a wall and
everyone's like yeah we don't know where
they may be then they do with Pink Floyd
[Applause]
long forgotten but then there's a dude
walking around on a wall and he's you
know walking around dressed as a wall
that's hysterical like I said other than
a couple these other characters that
like I said they they beat children are
threatened to be children but there are
a couple that are worse that do worse
things and one of these is named and
this is French and I took French but a
pair foot are which is French for father
whipper okay
not like a dude that whips
others but like a father who whips other
people hi good evidently whip and a whip
[Music]
yeah there should be a rapper named like
that with a whip daddy yeah is that does
anybody gonna be there's gonna be now
that I said it now there is and now
there's gonna be an ice cream flavor
named Belsnickel - who else Nichols yeah
and then would it be cool if they got
those two together yeah like he could be
on the package or like be on their
commercials or something okay so what
tell us about web day well well this guy
the legends surrounding him now he goes
around he dispenses lumps of coal and
stuff like that and floggings to the
naughty children Logging's I read it but
now that I'm like saying it out loud I'm
like holy crap so apparently this
character the legend surrounding him and
I don't know if it was actually based on
a real dude or whatever but the first
story that was told about him was goes
back to 1150 that was the one the first
story about him came out so this is a
very old legend now in some legends
he's an innkeeper but in other ones he's
a butcher now for some reason he kidnaps
three little boys the three little boys
are rich boys and they're on and they're
going down they're little rich boy way
it's just sounding bad already - yeah it
doesn't end well yes
spoiler alert always these grown men
with these children it's just it's
upsetting okay I know see what you guys
Rod's
so these three little rich boys are
walking down the street they're going to
enroll in a boarding school a religious
boarding school because they're they're
rich and pious and bright you know
saintly and whatnot so except the
butcher
you know whip daddy
him and his wife kidnapped the children
and kill them okay now there are
different versions about how they kill
them but the the most gory one is that
they give they drug the children they
slit their throats mmm and then cut them
up mmm and make him into a stew okay
yeah okay so generally however he kills
basically he chops up and eats three
children and st. Nicholas finds out
about this [ __ ] yeah even though this
kind of [ __ ] probably went on all the
time so I don't know why st. Nicholas
God suddenly got all butthurt about this
one particular but he just really liked
those particular kids I can write they
were the good ones they were good they
were the only three good children on
earth he's like [ __ ] the rest of them to
you but so st. Nicholas found out about
the kids and brought them back to life
okay
he pulled in Jesus he did okay yeah he's
like I don't know like how because they
were in pieces and they were in a stew
and if whip daddy ate the stew yeah then
did he resurrect it oh no I did right I
don't like the implication service maybe
just trans maybe he just what yeah just
poof anew I'm a came back there like
what that I was digestive tracts what
was slightly reversed time yeah I guess
that's what happened okay and so
basically st. Nicholas said because the
butcher was such an asshat that he had
to follow him around like forever huh
although so it was like punishment but
in a way why would it be punishment
because he gets to go he gets to live
forever he gets to follow Santa around
and beat children what she's super into
okay so I don't know why that's a
punishment that's it's a late Middle
Ages early Renaissance thinking you know
so they're I guess but yeah so that's
cruel cruel superstitious people sure
they're eating children all the time
when times got hard
well yeah me what else are you gonna do
with them they can't work in the field
right I mean especially when they're
just toddlers and they can't fire you
I've heard stories you know when he got
cold and they got hungry back then in
those days they ate kids I it wouldn't
starve it you know I know it's terrible
you guys in the modern age and stuff
like that but for a pragmatic standpoint
I mean until the kid is five or six
years old they can revert yeah yeah it's
like what and when they're really little
that it's where they can't go anywhere
so yeah there they are and you can just
we gotta make it through this winter we
got to feed all the other ones so yeah
Donner Party [ __ ] yeah some nasty [ __ ]
right here but Christmas you guys we've
always talked about the good old days
yeah not really
yeah I don't think I would go back I
would not go back to there I know
because yeah it sucks back then sure it
is you know I don't even want to go back
like 50 years and get [ __ ] polio hey
man flush toilets they have showers
didn't have a hot water didn't have any
they see when I'm dirty [ __ ] yeah no
toilet paper
damn yeah they had to wipe their asses
like catalogs and [ __ ] or pine cones
I saw a thing the other day about I
didn't even realize this is how [ __ ]
dumb I am about and I know we're going
off on a tangent but it's okay it's okay
I'm gonna do a break in a minute but um
but I saw a thing about the invention of
toilet people like the two guys that
invented toilet paper yeah I was like a
milestone the Scott company and it was
funny because at first they couldn't get
anybody to buy it because everyone was
too embarrassed yeah and everyone had
been using you know everyone had
outhouses then and they were just using
[ __ ] like printed catalogs to wipe
their butt with yeah so sure everyone's
ass just have like ink all over better
than using your sleeve okay I'm gonna
stop and take a break and then we will
come back and talk about the really
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
oh there's worse yeah okay so we'll be
right back in just a minute
watch out there's a new terror taking
over kitchens around the world
thrills chills mad cooking skills it
cooks a weekly podcast brimming with
recipes tips food fights seasonal
specials and guests galore hosted by
horror author amber felon hey that's me
a foodie with over 20 years experience
cooking baking and generally making a
nuisance of herself you've watched Food
Network you've read cookbooks but
nothing can prepare you for it cooks
coming to a device near you if you're
into cosplay corset Reese
steampunk gothic or rockabilly clothing
shoes and accessories then you must
visit subculture corsets and clothing
either online at www.binaryforecast.com
your entire purchase or when checking
out on their website use the discount
code 13 o'clock and receive a 10%
discount on your entire order and if
you're a full-figured girl don't worry
subculture carry sizes 4 through 4x and
they have men's clothing as well that's
subculture corsets calm and use discount
code 13 o'clock for a 10% discount go
check out their website now subculture
corsets calm or when traveling through
Jacksonville Florida stop in and check
out their store at the Avenues Mall oh
cast dead sexy podcasts I'm your host
Armando's Amelia Fridays exclusively on
project Entertainment Network where I
interview
authors publishers editors artists
filmmakers
narrators the lady from Walmart whoever
I feel like talking to that's every
friday podcast right here on project
entertainment network
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone there's a brand new podcast
starting on December 1st the Dead TV
podcast where we take shows from the
horror industry that had been cancelled
or ended and reviewed them episode by
episode starting with kindred be
embraced and Constantine you'll have to
stick around to see what the 3rd show
that we're doing immediately after those
joining me for this amazing new podcast
is mr. zenica hello everyone thanks for
having me
mr. Seneca is an event hostess of kinky
geeky and sexy parties around the
philadelphia area she has a flair for
the dramatic and is passionate about
zombies she also teaches on a wide
variety of BDSM topics including high
protocol in fact you can say she wrote
the book on it which you can find at her
website
WWL kentucky.com thanks so much I'm
happy to be here chris is a longtime
horror fan and turn that love of horror
into an almost decade-long radio show
called radio of horror he wrote a
children's Halloween book in 2012 called
give me something good to eat and has a
comic book forthcoming or hee genders
robs the entire accounts of Dracula
looking forward to that on the side he
also makes short horror films in
Massachusetts so how could I say no and
you can get all the updates about our
podcast on our Facebook page the dead to
you TV podcast and eventually a
forthcoming Twitter page as well so stay
tuned for the first episode coming
December 1st
there's hairos real and imaginary and I
write about them all paranormal
nonfiction or fiction rush day of
service
yes this table monster Red Menace the
tender grass fellow ever go to WWJD
AFRICOM or search Amazon for the Jenny
Ashford author page
okay Christmas child beating child
eating it's you know it's kind of a fun
so you know what's next on the road like
I said next time they're rostered now
here this one this is kind of cool this
one's kind of cool this is from Iceland
and like I said they had some pretty
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
oh I know this one now yeah well this is
okay this is like a whole expanded
universe and they need to [ __ ] make a
movie out of this [ __ ] right now well
I'm sure they've made them in Iceland
but they need to make like one over here
so I can actually see it some of you may
have heard of the Yule cat the Yule he's
and I'm not even gonna attempt to say
that Icelandic name cuz it's like that's
worse than Bjork's last name okay I
can't even say that but if you look up
you'll cat you'll say it this cat is
giant it's like not quite Godzilla size
it's not like catzilla but it pretty big
I mean it's bigger like winning an
elephant oh yeah yeah well when they
show like artistic depictions of the
Yule cat he's like sitting on a village
essentially so he's like as big as a
village okay and here's the thing now
thinking about you old cat he also eats
people all right and he eats children
but for a really petty reason if you
don't have new clothes before Christmas
Eve oh your ass is grass this cat will
eat you yeah and I'm like that seems
like the Yule cat I mean he's just
[ __ ] on the poor right don't if you
can't afford that that was an
adventurous miss Eve that was an
invention of the Taylors well it
probably wasn't they actually think it
was invented to get people to work
harder over the holiday season look good
so they would have enough money to get
new clothes for Christmas Eve so the
Yule cat wouldn't eat that yeah so so
yeah like I said it I did yeah and it
just looks like a tab you can Kelly well
they're different and like I've seen it
as a black cat I've seen it it's like
just if but it looks pretty much like a
regular cat except super super huge all
right
do the Romanian now you can't in real
men okay I can make that connection yeah
now associated with the you'll cat this
is like I said it's like a whole family
there are also the Yule Lads
okay and these are kind of like Santa
Clauses Santa Claus I but there are
usually about thirteen of them okay and
um like the apostles sort of and they
kind of um they will visit like if you
put your shoes out of the windows this
is also in Iceland during the 13 nights
before Christmas Eve like once a night
one of the Yule Lads will come and
they'll either bring you good [ __ ] or if
you were bad they will leave you a
rotting potato okay yeah now so they
come with a cat though well they're
associated with a cat because like I
said now the Yule Lads over time like I
think they kind of started out as their
own thing but then over time it kind of
grew to accompany to UM encompass the
Yule cat and also my one of my favorite
characters the gorilla she is supposed
to be the Yule Lads mother oh no and the
cat comes with her okay now she gorilla
is a monster oh good
she is like usually depicted as a really
big troll okay
or like an ugly witch okay and she's
really really big and here's the coolest
thing like when I was researching this I
love you Iceland I have to say in
Iceland there is a mountain I can't
remember the name of what the mountain
is but there is a humongous statue of
the gorilla play this really ugly troll
and in front of her is this big huge pot
and you can get in it and get your
pictures and it's like it is out there
all by itself it's just like on top of
this melt like
looking out over this valley this is a
statue of color yeah I think it looked
like it was God now I have to look at
the picture again it looked like it was
stone okay but but the gorilla or which
I think I'm pronouncing correctly she
actually was just she didn't get
associated with Christmas until the 17th
century before that she was just like a
generic troll that you scared your kids
with um she has a husband as well but I
can't pronounce his name they live in a
cave okay right like a troll does and
but you know in the 17th century she got
started to get associated with Christmas
and she later she got associated with
the Yule cat and also the old goats
there's also a you old yet cool cuz you
know cats because whatever and so she
has some kind of like magical force
ability she can tell when kids are being
bad so she's like Santa Claus sees you
when you're sleeping yada yada she's
like that so when it's Christmas she
comes out her cave mmm and comes down to
the town to find all the bad children so
she can eat him okay so she puts him in
her pot and she cooks him awesome and
eats him that's her favorite snack and
so they say and apparently if she gets a
lot of kids she'll make a big pot stew
out of him and man she can eat off that
all year kids must been pretty bad back
in those days scare him with these kind
of stories I bet you they were pretty
bad they were prey on psychos yeah so uh
so yeah so she lives she lives in a cave
with her husband and and the Yule Lads
who later like I said became the son of
her and also the Yule cats that's a
pretty [ __ ] crowded cave you'll have
to say maybe it's a really big one now
here's kind of this one actually is kind
of a fun one
speaking of witches and I had actually
heard of this one before but in Italy
they don't really have well I guess they
kind of Santa Claus but they have La
Befana
she is the
miss witch okay and she's but she's not
a bad witch she's kind of just like
Santa but she like rides around on a
broomstick alright and brings presents
it [ __ ] like that when did this start
you know I was I don't know it goes back
a long way but and actually it's
associated with Christianity a little
bit she actually doesn't come on
Christmas she comes on epiphany who was
just January 5th okay and um so I so I
guess they have Santa come on Christmas
and then she comes on Jan because like I
said God BAM he's [ __ ] kids man they
get so many presents yeah but um it's a
long stream of presents and monsters and
witches pretty much yeah and um so you
know she comes to and she puts candy
inside of shoes and stuff like that no
another thing that la Befana is said to
do is that she will sweep your floor
before she leaves cool so you know
pretty helpful yeah so it's like hey la
Befana cleaned up and left me a [ __ ] so
i can d/l she does that's pretty rad
pretty much I guess well the sweeping
this sweeping is that's like sweeping
out all the bad stuff from the last year
and then so it's like a symbolic
symbolic thing but yeah she's always I
mean she's always shown as like an ugly
hag like you know a traditional rich
witch on a broomstick except she just
brings presents I don't really know why
but um on the dark side of that there is
also another kind of Christmas witch
she's kind of more a goddess but she's
usually portrayed as a witch and she's
called Frau perc da huh and she like I
think like the gorilla she was kind of
like a goddess that kind of
transmogrified until like I specifically
you know like a specific Christmas
legend she is actually a lot more she
looks a lot like Krampus okay she has
cloven hooves uh-huh and she usually has
horns and she's really ugly and stuff
like that she's the same size as an old
person I guess so I don't think she's
big um some
some artwork I saw of her they show her
as having two faces one in the back of
her head you know what is it one more
your normal faces are on the back of her
head because she can be you know very
kind and loving and stuff like that but
you get on her bad side
and you know what her nickname is what's
it the belly slitter brow perk does
she's the bellies litter and what she
will do if you've been very good
children she will leave you silver coins
she'll put them in your shoes and stuff
like that
if you have been bad then she will slit
open your stomach take out all of your
internal organs and stuff your body with
rocks and hey survive well it doesn't
really go that far assuming you would
not okay I'm assuming you would not good
so she punishes bad children she also
punishes lazy people right like what if
she comes to your house and you haven't
spun all your flax right year or
whatever excuse me
then also she will slit your belly oh so
you know yeah not lazy anymore are ya
know cuz now you're dead she is actually
my favorite she's actually my favorite
one of all of this because she seemed
like the scariest and there's a really
great artwork of her what had spins
around well I don't know if the head
spins around or if she just yeah if she
just turns around is like oh man
[ __ ] it was just like that scene
in Amadeus where where he had that to
face mask on yes you guys know what I'm
talking about probably it's that black
mask okay so like I said Frau perked up
kind of like Krampus but worse like
cutting your stomach open and why not
and then the last one one our to talk
about now this one was actually I'm not
sure if it was based on a real guy
because it's very it's a very specific
area and it's a part of part France at
Lorain area I'm not really sure where
that is but his name is Hans trap that's
what he's called
and this legend started about the 15th
century and Hans trap was supposed to be
this you know really rich guy real
powerful guy but he was also a total
[ __ ] right and everybody around the
area like knew what an [ __ ] he was
and he was not only an [ __ ] I mean he
was on slopes a criminal he was like you
know kind of your general greedy bastard
he was just like taking everyone's money
and he was selfish instead of that but
also he was supposed to be a Satanist
all right yeah so he used black magic it
was like one thing though you know the
[ __ ] that the picture the drawing of
another shooter that's the drawing from
the Led Zeppelin album cover
yeah they had that one of the Led
Zeppelin's yeah and he was a Satanist
yeah maybe so a way to have an album
cover I think yeah I'll fine I'll put it
in the alright YouTube video but yeah so
um so yeah he was a Satanist using black
magic to you know keep his power and all
this other stuff now the Catholic Church
found out about all hans and of course
they didn't like it so he got arrested
he got taken before the pope and then he
was excommunicated oh my god that's all
they did
yeah didn't even bring mistake okay so
that yeah they let him go they're like
oh worship and say no that kind of said
well just get out just nothing back
we're not gonna hang you're nothing
wrong when did this supposedly happen
15th century okay
they were so burning witches rather yeah
certain places but I think I would just
depending on what well no we had a [ __ ]
ton of money that's why yeah you bought
bought as well yeah he's just like all
right just excommunicate me with him to
save this anyway what the [ __ ] time he
probably bribed him yeah so anyway they
let him go back to his hometown and
everybody in the town was like [ __ ] you
man and they you know he was like a
pariah yeah and so you know people would
just run away from him and stuff like
that and then all his money and land got
confiscated oh so now he's a bomb right
so yeah so he had to go be he had to go
be like the Unabomber he had to go like
he's a hermit out in the mountains and
[ __ ] like that he made a little shack
and sticks and [ __ ] like that and then
much like the Unabomber he went crazy
okay and kind of got more into Satan did
this really happen into the legend it's
alleged alleged okay I mean it might be
based out blew some based on a real guy
an around okay so you know he goes nuts
he's like getting more into Satanism
stuff and then he decides no what I'd
really like to do you know what's on my
bucket list I wanna eat a dude yeah you
know so he just like yeah he's like I
just wanna I just want him bite into
human flesh I just want to see what
taste like it always it always boils
down to eat somebody with yeah would be
with these medieval 's what what had
have been going on that it was the worst
possible thing that what happened so
maybe that was the worst thing they
could think that yeah maybe
either that or they were super like all
of them are super or secretly like maybe
people it's like man that guy looks
delicious
did you see that they're trying to say
the guise of savage yeah that's yeah
because you're yes because of the animal
human duality I guess that's probably
all it is so basically what he would do
is he would he wanted to catch a victim
to eat so he dressed up as a scarecrow
okay and he would go like wait in a
field
all right and for somebody to like yeah
so yeah yeah I know I'm like oh now some
serial killers out to make a movie that
we're in trouble yeah didn't they make
us they made a scarecrow harm I really
mini yeah so you know obviously a victim
happened by one day little shepherd boy
10 years old and so Hans trap caught him
and he could he caught him he stuck him
with a stick like just stab me with a
stick dragged him back to his a little
shack yeah and cut him up roast them and
evidently just as he was about to eat
the kid
God struck Han strapped with lightning
damn which I don't know why God didn't
strike with lightning before oh okay but
yeah but now you can't either
yes that's just that's too far that's
over the line yes God's a dick so say
yes so evidently you know Han strap got
burned to a crisp and apparently the
little cut-up boy BAE I guess he went to
heaven and then he got up there and Gabe
got a piece of his mind why he didn't
that's how that one ends and that's kind
of out that and so that's it medieval
just and so yeah that's how that one has
got with God struck him down so Hans
trap from that point on he became like a
legendary figure and for some reason he
got associated with Christmas so on
Christmas he goes around all the houses
dressed up like a scarecrow okay and
scares the [ __ ] out of kids and like is
like he's gonna eat up and [ __ ] like
that
and so you know what what the [ __ ] man
yeah what were these people thinking
friar got must have been that must have
been they were tripping back then I
guess they're just constantly tripping
all the time yeah but like I said I do
feel like and that's why I'm so glad
that like the legend of Krampus has kind
of gained such a big resurgence in this
country and stuff like that you know now
they have like Krampus parades and all
that kind of [ __ ] because I really like
you know I really think we need to
return to some of it aren't you no I
don't want to eat kids or nothing like
that but I just like I like all the dark
mythology around Christmas that we kind
of have lost right like it's been purged
out by the marketplace yeah and that's
kind of sucks because one of my favorite
things about Christmas was watching the
[ __ ] Christmas Carol know with all
the creepy ghosts since you like that
you scare the crap out of me no I was a
kid but I love that I love that kind of
[ __ ] I always like to scary rides it
that at Disney
when I was a little kid all over the the
fun ones yeah like you know Snow White
the widget come out oh yeah allowed that
oh my god that's good to know like the
the Haunted Mansion and then Space
Mountain IRA and the Pirates of the
Caribbean yeah parts of that were pretty
creepy you know I remember the the scary
stuff yeah I love being scared
and I don't know like kids nowadays
don't get that
well we and you and me were just talking
about this the other day that like I
mean in our generations like you know
you're a little bit older than me but
not much I was born in 1972 so um you
know I grew up in the 70s and 80s and we
had a lot less supervision back then
yeah they didn't have as much they
weren't reluctant to like what I mean I
my parents would go rent me slasher
movies yeah I just play the gasoline
yeah me too and so um like seven right
here's a little play and when we were
talking about like a lot of the kids
movies that came out in the 70s and 80s
were really scary yeah I mean look at
[ __ ] like what was that like watership
down yeah you know something I mean
that's good the crap out of me when I
was a little kid and even like Reagan
even [ __ ] like I rather got caught a
snare
yeah when the other ones geysers yeah I
remember that the other rabbits got
buried alive and they're trying to dig
their way to the surf yes construction
happened I still remember that that
scared the [ __ ] out of me in the
original the original cartoon of The
Hobbit yeah the very very first one yeah
yeah that was also pretty long two
dragons
yeah I remember that I like that better
than the Lord they pre-made the Lord of
the Rings right
I like the animated Lord of the Rings
that was pretty cool yeah I did too but
um you know so it seems kind of a shame
that you know that kind of dark because
the dark side of Christmas to me has a
lot more of the magic of the holiday
about it than the kind of good happy
clappy kind of [ __ ] you know what I mean
yeah it's like I like Christmas and
everything you know we celebrate
Christmas and all that kind of [ __ ] and
it's fun but I really like the whole
mystery
like oh it's dark wintertime and we're
all gonna gather around the fire until
creepy stories to each other and [ __ ]
like that
and I you know I just feel like not a
lot of that survived although like I
said it sighs now everything's sanitized
although like I said it does give me
hope that with all the Krampus stuff
coming back now that people are kind of
getting back into that and even like Tim
Burton with Nightmare Before Christmas
and yeah that kind of stuff so I do feel
like some people particularly in our
generation you know remember that that
kind of dark glamour like around
Christmas that that we kind of need to
get back and so that's why I really
wanted to do a show about like all these
[ __ ] Christmas monsters because it
seems like so many other cultures like
if Hank hung on to that yeah cuz we
never really had that we just had Santa
Claus like I said pretty much right I
mean because I mean the Dutch brought
over Christmas and for a while like the
Puritans didn't didn't like it because
it was paying into blah-dee-blah so it
didn't really even get celebrated as a
holiday until much later yeah I think
all the 18th century maybe I'd always
read that really Christmas didn't appear
as you know it until after the 40s
that's true I mean you know yeah they
had Christmas Day it was like an on and
off type thing during you yeah I don't
think it was this big a deal no I don't
think it was a big deal I mean but yeah
like all the trappings we see now like
the way Christmases nowadays is a pretty
recent yeah
invention but if I was in a red suit
reindeers flying and just the
commercialization of it started well now
forties I mean yeah wool commercial oh
wait off for sure came from the 40s that
was from a like a Montgomery Ward poem
jingle made that up yeah so Rudolph is
totally wait up the other reindeer were
around a long time soon they have with
Halloween if you yeah I think how the
Halloween that we know is really for
more of the forties yeah because the I
have seen photographs from the eighteen
hundreds early nineteen hundreds of kids
dressed up for Halloween but also an
adults dressed up for Halloween and the
costumes that they used bizarre like
paper bags over their heads and sacks
yeah they weren't very much disturbed
yeah it was scary kind of creepy looking
and they were
doing stuff during in the day time and I
don't know if they were actually
trick-or-treating it maybe they were
well the whole point of Halloween as far
as I know was that I mean that was the
night when the veil between the dead and
the Laura was really thin so you were
trying to keep away the ghosts and
spirits you were trying demons and stuff
so you were supposed to look scary yeah
so they wouldn't get you some of the
photos some of the photos I seen they're
almost kind of look like they had a
elements of Mardi Gras - some of it
looked like Mardi Gras so yeah that's
awesome French looking outfits in it
yeah but there's no telling you know
it's it's hard to we can project back on
what those people were thinking at the
time and any given in any given activity
they have you really don't know what was
going on unless you were there yeah
because you don't really have I mean you
don't have a context and you can't I
mean as much as you can use your
imagination you're never you're never
gonna know and you're never gonna be
able to unless somebody wrote it down in
detail at the time yeah but you know as
we've kind of seen with this show it
seems like Christmas and Halloween are
actually a lot more similar than so Tim
Burton wasn't far off or that Nightmare
Before Christmas thing because Christmas
like I said it was always kind of a
creepy because it's midwinter yeah so
you know you can see everyone's kind of
huddled together and you know they're
hoping for a new year but it's all dark
and cold and [ __ ] like that so you know
monsters and whatnot so um I guess we'll
wrap it up right okay so hope everybody
has a very happy holiday whatever it is
you celebrate or whether you don't tell
them right now I give you [ __ ] whatever
we got a tree we'll do some [ __ ] but so
oh also we have still have t-shirts
available and I remind you every single
time but you know go buy some because we
need money for next Christmas and
that'll do you want to say anything make
sure to press the bell if you're if
you're listening to us on YouTube
there's a little bell near the
subscription bar and get your updates
you see you always want to be updated so
notice that YouTube doesn't work the way
it used to see subscribe to a channel
you won't get notifications from them on
a regular basis without pressing that
bill LLC I didn't even know that yeah
thanks YouTube yeah
whatever anyway so have a happy holiday
and tune in next week bye bye
[Music]